putting down their drills for drills
these are some of the men who have
helped build the stadiums for the Qatar
World Cup and now they're getting to
meet some of the stars who will shine in
them
I'm an electrical technician also three
and a half years in Albert stadium in
electrical ignition operation
so it's good what's your favorite player
a measurement yeah had it not been for
the beautiful game these two groups of
men with their different languages and
backgrounds would probably never have
met but football has brought them
together
we're just south of qatar's capital Doha
in a city called al-wacra This is where
England will base themselves through
this world cup and it's also a place
where many migrant workers live now this
is one of several Community engagement
workshops taking place and England have
chosen to support this particular
community
England's fa has been vocal on the
subject of workers rights they and
others like the Netherlands and
Australia have called for compensation
for workers who have died been injured
or faced unpaid wages while building
stadiums and other venues they also want
a permanent migrant workers Center
I don't think we're politicians and
we'll we never will be politicians in
terms of how we look at things but I
think in terms of what the squad's done
over the last few years and how much
they've helped people I think that comes
with the territory of what the boys have
done what I will say is that we're here
to do as much as we can we can do
everything but what we can do is try and
help people as much as we can tournament
organizes stress improvements have been
made in the living conditions of
hundreds of thousands of Migrant workers
a minimum wage has been established and
the so-called kafala system which meant
workers had to get approval from their
employers to switch jobs or leave the
country has been abolished
the international labor organization in
Qatar agrees but also says more efforts
are needed so that all workers can
benefit
it will take time to fully Implement
these changes and challenges do remain
these include dealing with retaliation
against workers who wish to change jobs
more also need to be done to reduce wage
payment violations and ensure timely
access to Justice
domestic workers must also benefit fully
from the labor reforms this includes
respect for working times and the right
to at least one day off per week
these workers have built the stadiums in
which the England team can pursue its
World Cup dreams and as a final thank
you the England players give them
tickets to see their hard work become
reality
Joanna gajaroska Al Jazeera alwacra